the world
thanks so much thanks everyone I'm
laurentia I'm very glad to be here and
talk about this joint work with imba
Omar and omnipredictors for constrained
optimization
any talks in this Workshop mention
omnipredictors and indeed omniproduction
is a very powerful notion that allows us
to train a single model that can be
easily adapted to minimize many
different loss functions
and the goal of this thought is very
simple I'm going to show you that the
idea of omnipredictors can be applied to
a much broader range of tasks and
specifically to constrained optimization
and hopefully this will make the notion
of omnipredictors more applicable in
practice
so if you are watching this video on
YouTube hit like subscribe and write
nice comments I really appreciate it
very good
[Applause]
I'll do it
um
I start by giving an introduction to
omnipredictors so omnipredictors work in
scenarios where we take actions to
minimize loss so just to set up the
notation I'm going to give you some very
simple examples
so a graduate school needs to decide on
whether to admit a student or not so
these are the decisions these are the
actions that the school can take
and in order to choose which action you
take let's suppose the score makes
predictions uh about whether the student
will be successful or not
and let's say in this case there's a
loss associated with failure to admit a
successful student
throughout the talk I will use lowercase
a to denote an action and I will use
capital A to denote a set of actions
that we can choose from and for the
purpose of this talk let's focus on
binary outcomes
denoted by what
and the loss is a function of the action
and the outcome and it's a real number
it is a very simple setup but it
captures many examples
um there's another example where the
action corresponds to the number of loan
we want to approve for a client and in
this case we try to predict whether the
loan will be repaid or not and if you
want to maximize our profit then the
loss is the negative profit
so in such slow minimization problems if
we know the distribution of the outcome
then it is very easy to find the best
action to take that minimizes the
expected loss here the outcome is binary
so it follows a Bernoulli distribution
with mean p and if we know the value of
P then we can just easily find the
optimal action we just write down the
expected expected loss find the action
that minimizes it I will use kl to
denote the optimal action to take
for many loss functions they are closed
form solutions to this optimal action so
indeed KL is a function that is usually
extremely easy to compute
so that you can meet as many students as
there are potential successful yeah so
the question is uh can we just in the
first example admit admit everyone so in
this case that's what you should do but
uh in practice there are constraints and
the title of this talk is omnipredictors
for constrained optimization
so hold on
um
um yeah so in practice usually we're
dealing with much more challenging
scenarios we don't know the distribution
of the outcome and we have to learn the
distribution from data
and we want to automate the process so
that we can efficiently assign actions
to say thousands of individuals
so to model such more challenging
scenarios we assume that there's
underlying distribution D over
individuals and outcomes
um and we collect data points from this
distribution to an IID from this
distribution and we learn from these
data points to get a model that can
assign an action to each individual
and our goal is to minimize the expected
loss over the distribution d
this slow minimization problem is
standard in the machine learning
literature people have to developed many
different algorithms for minimizing
various loss functions and an easy
observation here is that for different
loss functions the model you get from
minimizing those loss functions are
quite different so it is obvious that if
a learning algorithm wants to solve this
loss minimization problem it needs to
know what the loss function is
and the idea of omniproduction is to do
last memorization without knowing the
loss function and how could that be
possible so the idea is that the loss is
revealed after training time but before
the actions are taken so let me explain
this using a pipeline uh in standard
loss memorization we have a we have a
learner which collects data and knows
the loss function it outputs a model and
the model can take actions assign
actions to individuals
in omnipiction we also have a learner
which collects data but the learner does
not know the loss function
and after the learner produces a
predictor the loss is revealed to a
post-processing procedure
and uh the and after that the
post-processing procedure uh assigns
actions to individuals
so uh what makes omniprediction powerful
is that for different loss functions we
don't have to train different models we
can use the same exact fixed predictor
and the only thing that changes with the
loss function is the post-processing
procedure which it's supposed to be
extremely simple and extremely efficient
so what this means is that on the
omniproduction allows us to adapt to
different loss functions that may change
over time for loss functions that are
unknown at training time so indeed
omniproduction is very powerful
formally we say a predictor is an
omnipredictor if for any loss function L
from a family of loss functions the
expected loss achieved by KL of P of X
is upper bounded by the expected loss
achieved by any hypothesis C in the
hypothesis class capital c plus some
small error Epsilon
and here this is our KL function plays
the role of the post-processing
procedure and it is indeed extremely
simple as we defined at the beginning of
the talk uh KL is the optimal action to
take if we pretend that the outcome y
follows the Bernoulli distribution with
mean p of X and as I said usually KR is
extremely easy to compute
and in this definition the predictor p
is fixed for all the different loss
functions and the only thing that
changes with the loss function is the
post-processing KL that's exactly what
we want
the idea of only prediction was
introduced by Parachute Adam Omer Watson
Udi and this idea was further explored
in
um a follow-up paper through the lens of
outcome indistinguishability
so the main results of these papers is
that omnipredictors not only exist but
also they are they can be efficiently
learned from data and the very mild
assumptions on the loss function
this is an informal statement of several
theorems from these papers there are
many other different versions the
details are not very important that's
not the point the point here is that we
do have algorithms that can learn
multi-calibrated predictors or
multi-accurate predictors Michael has
told us that it gave us election on such
algorithms in his talk for example
and indeed some of these algorithms have
been implemented in practice
so what this theorem tells us is that
indeed omniproduction is practical
so if we try to apply Omni prediction to
practice
we realize that many problems in
practice are not just lost minimization
they also require constrained
satisfaction
so for example in the admission setting
we may have a budget constraint which
limits the number of students we can
admit
and we may also have a various
constraints because some demographic
groups have been historically
discriminated and we want to take
affirmative actions to admit a fair
number of students from those groups
and such constraints also apply to the
loan application setting
so in in this settings
you you might find that the loss
function doesn't quite change over time
they may change they may not but it is
very natural for the constraints to
change over time we may have a different
budget each year and the fairness policy
may change as we better and better
understand how to protect disadvantaged
groups
so in these scenarios it would be
extremely helpful if we could have an
omnipredictor that allows us to adapt to
the changing constraints so that we
don't have to retrain a new model every
time we have a new budget or every time
the fairness policy changes
so
um the and as I will show you in this
talk uh indeed we show that we can
construct omnipredictors for such
constraint optimization problems
so in other words what we will do is to
add constraints into this pipeline
uh of course in here in omnifiction the
learner knows neither the loss function
nor the constraints and they are
revealed after training time and only to
the post-processing procedure and again
we want the post-processing to be
extremely simple and efficient
a constraint optimization problems we
consider in this talk will be of this
general form in as a objective function
F0 and many constrained functions FJ I
will come back to this formulation later
but here I will just mention that in our
paper we consider even more General
versions of constrained problems where
we combine different constraints and
even different objectives using
arbitrary Ellipsis functions but that is
beyond the scope of this talk
any questions at this point
so
um
the first thing we need to do in order
to construct I mean predictors for
constraint problems is to Define Army
predictors for constrained problems
so to do that we let's take a closer
look at the an unconstrained definition
where we have this KL function that
plays the role of the post-processing
and this scale function can be
understood using this following
optimization problems over a new
distribution DP
which we call the simulated distribution
the BP is defined after we obtained a
predictor p and DP is defined so that
the marginal distribution of the
individual X is the same as the marginal
distribution of x from the true
distribution B but the distribution of
the outcome Y is the Bernoulli
distribution with mean p of x
so what this says is the DP tries to
stimulate the true distribution by first
drawing the individual X from the true
distribution but then it generates fake
outcomes using the binary distribution
with mean p of x
and almost by definition of KL and DP
you will realize that KL P of X is the
solution to the optimization problem on
the simulated distribution
so what this says is that the
post-processing procedure is equivalent
to solving the problem on the simulated
distribution
so in the unconstrained setting we we do
have a very simple solution to the
problem on the simulated distribution so
that's why we get a very simple
post-processing KL
let's generalize this idea to the
constraint setting
and you realize that if we bring
constraints into this problem then
suddenly it becomes challenging to keep
the post-processing is simple so it will
illustrate this using an example we have
two individuals X1 and X2 we try to
minimize the squared loss and let's try
to solve the post-processing problem
which means that we already have a
predictor p and we just try to do
post-processing by solving this
optimization problem on the simulated
distribution DP
now let's suppose the marginal
distribution of X is the uniform
distribution and the predictor P makes
two predictions P1 and P2 for the two
individuals
and in this case it's very
um so so by the definition of DP we know
that the conditional expectation of the
outcome y given individual x i is equal
to Pi
so in this case it's very easy to figure
out what are the optimal actions so uh
they are of course given by the KL
function and in this case is the squared
loss which is a proper law so the KL
function is just identity function the
optimal action to take is just the
predictions themselves
let's try to add constraints to this
problem
so we'll consider the simplest possible
constraint you can possibly imagine
which says that there's a total budget
of one which means that there is a
average budget one-half per individual
um
and in this case we can figure out still
figure out what is the optimal action to
take so it's given by projecting the
point P1 and P2 to the feasible region
which is given by the bottom left
triangle of the square
this corresponds to the constraint A1
Plus A2 smaller than one
so in this case you'll realize that
there's a problem
because now the optimal action to take
for the first individual depends on the
prediction of the second individual
and um in in general it is very easy to
come up with examples where the optimal
action to take for y individual depends
on the prediction of all the other
individuals
so what this means that first of all uh
in order to Define Omni prediction for
constrained problems we can no longer
use the KL function we need to consider
much more powerful post-processing
but then this leads to the question of
keeping post-processing simple how can
we still keep post-processing Simple
when they are global
so we solve this problem by making some
assumptions
so we assume that the population is
partitioned into a small number of
groups you can think of these groups as
demographic groups and we assume that
the optimization problems we are dealing
with uh have this group structure so
this means that these functions F0 and
FJ they don't directly depend on the
individual X but instead it depends on
the group membership G of X of that
individual
and this whole similarly for the
constraints
so even with this group structure
assumption our problem is still much
more General than the loss minimization
problem considered in previous
omnipredictors work
um the reason is that in previous work
the loss function L does not directly
depend on the individual X at all but
here we at least allow it to pan to
depend on the group membership and we
also have constraints of course so that
makes our problem more General
and uh also many natural constraints are
group constraints they they do naturally
have this group structure for example
for Budget constraints
um they are group constraints even if
all the individuals belong to the same
group it's an overall budget constraint
but there are many
interesting and famous group fairness
constraints such as statistical parity
equalizer equalized equal opportunity
equalized us
these are all uh these are all group
constraints
cool so this means that we are very
happy with making this assumption they
still they still allow us to consider
most of the interesting problems
once we make this assumption I will show
you that now we are able to make the
post-processing easy so the post
processing still needs to be Global that
cannot be avoided because just because
of the example I just showed you
but here we can try to make it efficient
to compute
the trick is to partition the
individuals into blocks
so here um we have three groups so they
form a partition of the population and
also we have a predictor and by standard
discretization we can assume that the
predictor outputs value zero Epsilon to
Epsilon and so on and that gives us
another partition of the population and
we take the intersection of these
partitions to define the blocks
each block consists of individuals that
have the same G value and the same
p-value
and the observation here is that
although the optimal action you take
still needs to be Global they have to
depend on the predictions of all the
other individuals
they however does not depend does not
need to depend on the on the identity of
an individual in the specific block the
reason is that this optimization problem
itself because of this group structure
does not differentiate between two
individuals in the same group so there
is no reason for the solution to depend
on the uh to differentiate two
individuals in the same group
so what this means is that we can
restrict our attention to this cgp class
which consists of functions that are
constant on each block
so here we assume that it's a partition
of the population and that's one
structured for the constraint
so it is a fixed
expectation for all the constraints and
the objects
um
so uh I just say that this is not
exactly true we need some for example
convex the Assumption so that we can
apply genes and semicolons in the right
direction
or we may need to randomize our actions
so either way
um but those technical details are
another Point here uh the point is that
this group structure allows us to reduce
the post-processing problem to a linear
program or a convex program with a few
number of variables that the number of
variables is just corresponds to a
number of blocks and the number of
blocks grows linearly with the number of
groups so if the number of groups is not
too large then we can efficiently sound
the cost processing plot
so there's one small challenge that I
want to mention
is that in order to solve the
post-processing problem we also need to
know the probability that a random
individual lies in each block and in
order to solve this problem we notice
that these probabilities do not depend
on the actual optimization task we are
trying to solve so we can estimate these
probabilities at training time and store
these estimations together with the Omni
predictor to get an odd meta on the
predictor and this leads to the view of
omnipredictors as data structures and
not just predictors I'm happy to chat
more offline about this new viewpoint
but I don't have time to say very much
in this talk
so now that we know the post-processings
can be efficiently computed we can
meaningfully Define omnipredictors for
constrained loss minimization
suppose we have a constrained task T
which is of course revealed after we've
already trained a prediction
and we want to solve this task T so we
want to compete with the best hypothesis
the best hypothesis that solves this
task from a hypothesis class capital c
so we use the Benchmark to denote this
hypothesis that we want to compete with
and since we already have a predictor we
don't want to solve this task from
scratch so we consider this
post-processing task which is defined on
the simulated distribution DP
and we solve this task uh using a
different hypothesis called C Prime
and we are most interested in the case
where we have group structure so this in
this case we choose C Prime to be this
class cgp which is defined to consist of
functions that are constant on each
block
and I just mentioned this task PP can
indeed be solved efficiently and in
particular the complexity for solving
this task is independent of the original
hypothesis class capital c
now we say a predictor p is an
omnipredictor if for every task T from a
large family of tasks and its
corresponding task DP
the model see post process that we can
indeed efficiently compute
set is a good solution to the original
task t
which can be much harder to solve
um and uh in particular this means that
uh see post process satisfies the
constraints of the original task and it
achieves
uh smaller or equal objective value than
C benchmark
of course as usual we need to take an
error parameter into our definition but
the details are not very important here
questions
so now we now that we've defined uh
omniproduction for constrained problems
we show that we can indeed construct
such geometry predictors so we do that
through this technical Emma which gives
a sufficient condition for
omniprediction I don't have time to
describe dilemma in detail but I will
just say that dilemma allows us to re
reconstruct the results in previous work
in a streamlined way the previous
omniproduction results
and not only that this dilemma allows us
to construct omnipredictors in our
constraint setting and to State our
result we need to generalize the Notions
of multi-accuracy multi-calibration to
the group setting so we Define group
multi-accuracy to be basically
multi-accuracy condition on each group
and similarly for calibration and
multi-calibration
and now we can State our main result and
I think you might already expect it I
mean main result basically just says
that if a predictor satisfies this group
of multi-accuracy group multiple
calibration conditions then they are
omnipredictors for constrained
optimization problems uh if if there is
a fixed group partition Gene for for a
fixed group partition G
um the the exact statement of this
theorem is uh is not very important
since it's an informal statement anyways
um the and there are many other versions
of this theorem in our paper and I just
say that uh
um basically our ethereum subsumes
previous zombie predictor results
uh in the sense that we now have
constraints and we have multiple groups
and there are lots of versions some make
more assumptions some make fewer
assumptions uh and I just say that even
the most restrictive settings supports
many of the interesting loss functions
and constraints that we we like to think
about
um
so finally I would just briefly mention
an interesting exploration that we did
in this paper which is motivated by the
observation that fairness constraints
alone do not prevent all harms and in
particular we could be giving a fair
amount of loan to each group but we are
not giving them the loan to the people
that are mostly likely to repay the loan
from certain groups and by doing this
we're causing harm to those groups
because potentially we are making the
economic situation for those groups
worse and worse
when we ask this question of in what
cases can we make sure that we give more
loans to the people that are more
predicted more likely to repay the loan
within each group
and indeed we show that under some mild
monitoring it's the assumptions we can
ensure this rank this property that we
call rank preserving
uh and that is the end of my talk thank
you
[Applause]
for your emotions
um so it's the same vulnerability
assumption like if you have a plastic
printer for C then for example you can
uh we can just run the usual
multi-calibration algorithm but on on
the group separately so the group
structures
yeah
yeah and this year we're assuming that
we only have a small number of groups
does it make sense to put this in an
even more General context of just convex
optimization or something like this like
could you define and
Omni convex Optimizer or something
something like this yeah good question
uh I need to think about it but I feel
that
the the problems we are considering
already pretty General uh but we should
just
um or if you have uh your current ideas
on what are the more General forms of
the problem
okay thank you